sorry to tell you guys this um I don't
like to give you bad news but eggs have
just been found out to cause heart
disease
a new study 30,000 people there was a
well at least an association with higher
risk of dying from consuming too many
eggs so if you're adding 300 milligrams
of additional cholesterol every single
day that's going to increase your risk
from cardiovascular disease by 17
percent and an 18 percent increased risk
of dying that's pretty scary
I'm being very sarcastic I pretty much
have to do one of these videos every
single week don't I first of all the
diet data was another question here so I
just want to give you one of the
questions okay over the past 12 months
how often in your lunch did you consume
deli-style ham or light or low-fat or
fat-free meats almost never or never
about 1/4 of the time about 1/2 the time
about 3/4 of the time almost always okay
so the list went on and on and on and on
right first of all who's going to
remember all the things that they ate
and and how do you know if they're true
right so you have that so the data was
collected during one single visit it
didn't look at patterns over a period of
time it was a one-shot deal and they're
gonna determine this data and surprise
the study was partially funded by the
American Heart Association alright so
the few questions for you did you know
that the body makes cholesterol okay you
did okay
did you realize that the body makes
3,000 milligrams per day maybe not right
that would be equivalent to consuming 14
eggs every single day and they're
telling you and that eating 300
milligrams is going to increase your
risk or heart disease it's not not true
okay in fact I have a couple studies
here well show you that here's one an
eggs serum cholesterol and coronary
heart disease and I'll put links down
below
it has concluded that within the range
of egg intake of this population
differences in egg consumption were
unrelated to blood cholesterol levels or
to coronary heart disease incidence
here's another one
dietary cholesterol from eggs increased
plasma HDL okay here's another one
dietary cholesterol from eggs increase
the ratio of total cholesterol to
high-density lipoprotein cholesterol and
humans okay this is a meta-analysis so
HDL is considered good cholesterol right
so it didn't say that it actually
increased the bad cholesterol see eggs
are very very healthy I consume four
eggs every single day I've done this for
about 35 years my cholesterol is fine my
heart arees are clear of any type of
plaquing or calcium deposits eggs are a
really good source of choline and
choline is essential to prevent a fatty
liver and one last point I want to bring
up about these questionnaire so-called
credible studies there are so many
variables that like why don't we why
don't they say it was mushrooms that
were linked to heart disease you know
why do they pick out eggs will you know
why because key though is becoming more
popular it's higher in fat it goes right
up against the companies that sell
refined carbohydrates and sugars anyway
you don't have to worry about consuming
eggs they're totally healthy make sure
that they're pasture raised and organic
and an egg is actually near-perfect
and it's a nutrition profile it has
almost all the vitamins and minerals
that fat soluble vitamins and it's a
great protein healthy fat low carb keto
friendly food alright thanks for
watching
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it